you just wrapped on a project that's in
theaters now yes yes yes the movie is
called independent film they got
purchased by Anchor Bay studios it's
called ten years it's basically a high
school reunion but it has ridiculous
amount of star power to it from Channing
Tatum to rosario Dawson - Jenna Tatum -
ari Graynor Aaron you Scott Porter Ron
Livingston Anthony Mackie Brian Geraghty
Amanda clip Chris Pratt Aaron you me
Maggie
otters so many names in this movie Ron
Livingston directed by Jamie Linden who
he wrote We Are Marshall Dear John and
yet he wrote and directed this this
great a Samba love cast and it was
improv a lot of it was improv majority
of it was it right there was a script we
you know it was basically a two and a
half months of you know intense star
power and around this you know this guy
from Miami Florida who was just soaking
it all in very intimidating every day
but once you get comfortable it's kind
of one of those things it's like okay
let's get to Fargo
let's do it but the names be you know
that came with this movie was was just
unbelievable just to be part of it I was
just like oh my god this is this is it
but you know man was it huh it was tough
I'll just say that the first couple of
days were pretty tough because you know
the star part their their use of this so
I had to start off the morning going
through my routine and then of course
throwing up a little bit but you know
and then get I know butterflies
first couple days are rough but I got
over it what did you learn from watching
all those names I said a lot of those
it's it's tough because it was such a
big huge cast so lose kind of one of
those things where you had to I had to
nitpick certain people's brains whenever
I get the chance to since it was a cast
of you know 18 actors it's kind of hard
to do that but being around and plus
you're in a town like Albuquerque no man
to go you're stuck so you have to you
know kind of like blend and learn I
learned a lot from certain actors
certain actors were kind of private to
themselves so you don't know how they
got to their routine and some of them
you guys said I got to notice and learn
and okay kind of imitate a little at all
and I did the same thing okay okay but
being around that power I can never take
that experience without that was just
unbelievable what did you see them do
that they were they the ones that were
always studying their script they
weren't just casting aside well I mean
you said it was improv so what were they
doing to get into that character my
favorite story was a disguise
unbelievable act at Chris Pratt he's on
the show called Parks and Recreation and
I was thought I'm watching him hit and
his scene he's he's very intoxicated but
this one in one scene he's like supposed
to be over the limit and I'm noticing
him doing certain things like you know
having ice in his mouth numbing his
mouth and slapping his face around
making his face like reddish wow this
guy is really getting into character
he's hopping around then suddenly action
he's completely into it and I was like
god this guy's brilliant it just took
him literally a couple minutes just to
get into that zone and suddenly he was
just in it immediately and once they cut
he goes into it goes through his routine
again he goes right back in so it was
those it was a lesson learned and you're
like okay I gotta leave some bounds to
go all you need is help returning but
yeah I learned a lot
what was your character my character I
played were all basically friends just
be reuniting at the Univ student at the
reunion and I play like a real close
friend to Anthony Mackie and Brian
garetty's character and Garrett he
brings his wife who is played by RV
Plaza and yeah and then the story takes
off from there so you know you play off
that and how did you get into your
character if it's mostly well the thing
that was cool about it is that he
basically the director wrote the story
basically the character's name is me so
I really didn't have to do too much I
mean the toughest part is that you're
they're shooting it for two months it's
H days you know suppose
a party so you know when you're partying
is cool and I'm not like you know one of
those guys who drinks a lot so I had to
get into drinking and that's tough for
me so I got into that for the whole said
and that's one thing yeah I'll say it
was pretty fun because you want to be
into the moment so every night was one
of those you know keep the party going
we're all good friends and stayed this
way for a while what did the director do
to build like a comradery on set so that
you really looked well the good thing
was it was winter and it was Albuquerque
so it's cold and there's not too many
things to do because the University
everybody's home away so you're we were
in downtown in a hotel which we shot in
Sauer rooms already there so we really
didn't leave so you basically there for
two months stuck in this place because
there's nothing to do really so that's
the greatest part about it you're forced
to become you know out of buddies or
real close friends because you know you
communicate with each other every day
yeah yeah almost two months and you fly
back to LA do you feel like that's what
he said well we have a wrap party in
Vegas which was cool excited flew us out
there and then we came back here it was
funny because I had to come back praying
that I had my nine-to-five job cuz I've
been a long way so long they flick us
out in an expensive jet which was crazy
and I immediately went home came here
got dressed and went sis takes my
nine-to-five guy I was like from you
know if you believe in heaven to hell it
was exactly like that Nicole instance
but the whole thing the whole time I was
thinking when we're wrapping is like
okay everybody here is already
established actor they're going on to
their next project so this is nothing
for that me I got a pray that I get
something else or not have to attack the
block and see what's next what's next
yeah that's what was my mindset as soon
as I got back
what am I gonna do next
you